où
à
un coin de chine perdu dans les yvelines
le jardin il y situe à saint rémy
l'honorer est un havre de paix c'est le
premier et seul jardin traditionnel
chinois en france
les gangs propriétaire du lieu se sont
lancés dans cette aventure en 2004 en
famille ma mère est diplômé architecte
dplg de l'école d'architecturé de
versailles et mon père est
diplômé en doctorat d'horticulture du
potager du roi on exploitait une
pépinière à l'époque pour les grandes
surfaces et à l'occasion de l'année de
la chine en france on s'est dit qu'il
fallait créer un jardin chinois pour
montrer ou aux européens que la chine
avait également une très belle culture
le jardin se divise en trois parties un
jardin des pivoines un jardin des bonsaï
est un genre dans les traits qui
s'inspire de ceux de soude chauds situés
en chine
le parcours est parsemé de statut
pavillon et bassins d'inspiration
chinoise en harmonie avec la nature au
jardin chinois traditionnellement il est
conçu par les laiteries chinois pour
retrouver la nature chez eux dans une
cour fermée et ils vont essayer de
mettre dans cet espace clos dans des
enceintes de murs tous les éléments qui
vont retrouver dans la nature selon la
philosophie chinoise s'est notamment le
fonds de cheville les cinq éléments
le yin et le yang selon le taoïsme etc
au programme ateliers de calligraphie
instruments de musique peinture jeux
traditionnels chinois et visites guidées
un véritable voyage dans l'empiré du
milieu